the fact that i megan mccain co-host of
the view
uh i don't know when or how i will be
able to get a vaccine because
the rollout for my age range and and my
health is is so
nebulous megan mccain's got the internet
talking again
i mean sometimes i'm calm sometimes i'm
not the 36 year old co-host of the view
made these controversial statements on
monday
this rollout has been a disaster i i'm
over dr fauci
during a discussion regarding dr fauci's
latest updates about coven 19
vaccinations
the tv personality didn't hold back in
her criticism of his handling of the
pandemic
i have no idea when and how i can get it
i want to get it if you call me at three
o'clock in the morning
i will go anyplace at any time to get it
in addition megan has taken issue with
the rollout of vaccinations across the
country
the idea that i can get vaccinated and i
won't be able to see friends and nothing
in life changes
and they were going to have to wear
masks forever i i don't understand the
downplaying of getting the vaccine
because right now we should be wanting
as many
americans as possible to get a vaccine
social media quickly responded to
megan's comments
with this remark in particular getting
the most feedback
the fact that i megan mccain co-host of
the view
i don't know when or how i will be able
to get a vaccine because
the rollout for my age range and and my
health is is so
nebulous i have no idea when and how i
can get it i want to get it if you call
me at three o'clock in the morning
i will go anyplace at any time to get it
one person wrote on twitter more
vulnerable people
should get priority while another simply
told her to sit this one out
yeah you probably could get your shot
but you're going to go outside and be
surrounded by people who have not gotten
their shot and they don't
know yet whether how protected you're
going to be
during the show whoopi goldberg offered
another view
this is all stuff that we'll know when
the science
makes sense or we could have them just
say yeah and then
we'll get him on the other side when
he's wrong after the taping
megan continued the discussion on social
media writing on twitter
many of you can keep worshipping at the
altar of fauci
i'm not a phony i will not go on tv and
lie saying one thing privately
and another on air this is my opinion
we need someone else in charge of
coronavirus messaging and
leadership megan gave e.t her reaction
to frequently drawing controversy on the
long-running talk show in 2019.
i try and just remind myself that i'm
representing 50 of the country
i'm representing a bunch of women even
though i only have one chair and
it's really important i also try and
think of as cheesy as it sounds um what
elizabeth hasselbeck used to mean to me
when i was young because i used to watch
the view in college
and she was really such an icon for
young republican women and
i hope i'm giving that to anyone that's
watching i know there's like people in
the middle of the country that feel like
they're really happy that someone's
representing them